hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal und zwar spiele ich mal wieder
gott simulator wir sehen
warum liegt eine tote frau neben mir ich
habe keine ahnung was hier schon wieder
abgeben allerdings herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einer was ist damit die
letzte kind schon wieder los hier
herzlich willkommen wie heute zu einer
neuen folge
warum fliegt ein helikopter lang
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einer
neuen episode dosimeter mit mir euren
lieblings youtube von hinten bevor wir
genau da fliegen wir es mal vor's hier
wieder losgeht mit 51 kg alles mögliche
quelle das ist das fahrrad juristisch
starace complete the race is possible
ok dann machen wir erst 13 21 ich habe
keine ahnung was hier irgendwie abgeht
ich muss erdrücken oh mein gott ich hab'
ich bin hin ich bin nicht mal durch den
staat durch gekommen also los gehts
freude ich habe keine ahnung wo wir
genau lang fahren sollen ich habe dich
hab ich über dich bitte hätten doch
schon durch gefahren also wir sind jetzt
schon bei fast einer minute und er nimmt
jetzt erst an dass wir durch diese teile
durchfahren also ich habe da wirklich zu
beginn ordentlich rein geschützen m ich
wollte aber eigentlich bevor das video
so richtig losgeht kurz etwas sagen und
auch mein gott ich rechts fahren müssen
ich wollte eigentlich etwas sagen bevor
das video losgeht und zwar in aller
erster stelle dass soeben ein neuer
podcast online gegangen ja danke für den
wenn auch sehr kleine nach klaus auf
jeden fall ist gerade auf spotify apple
music eppelborn ich bin ich bin einfach
scheiße in diesem spiel du eben ist ein
neuer podcast online gegangen auf allen
möglichen podcast plattformen whatever
eine neue folge die kunden mit sandra
und mir will man wieder über gott und
die welt
wir haben wieder kein richtiges thema
mein linkes dazu auf jeden fall unten in
der video beschreibung ein paar sekunden
später
das ist nicht wahr dass es nicht wahr
das auto da hinten hat einfach mein
fahrrad mitgenommen
hier schaut euch das an wartet das ist
das ist nicht wahr sein fahrrad
was passiert hier jetzt gerade herzlich
willkommen bei glätte mit luca ich habe
auch keinen plan warum diese komische
frau hier jetzt die ganze zeit auf
meinem rücken reitet aber okay wir
nehmen das einfach mal so hin
die zweite sache die ich sagen wollte es
ich wollte mich wert um gefahren ich war
was macht der typ da hinten da gab
dieses dieses spiel das ist das ist
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen ich
wollte auf jeden fall mal wieder einer
person auf instagram ein shoutout geben
und zwar der person namens sexy
unterstrich sandra sie hat dieses tolle
spagat bild hier von sander ge
photoshops also schaut auf jeden fall
mal gerne auf ihrem instagram profil
vorbei und falls einer von euch
eventuell in irgendeinem nächsten video
formieren auch ein insider bekommen will
dann verlinkt laser luca auf euren
bildern also markiert mich da einfach
dann sehe ich die und was entdecken was
ist denn mit diesen typen los ist denn
jetzt diese person hier wirklich die
ganze zeit auf meinem rücken oder kann
ich dir irgendwie loswerden oder wenn
ich hier irgendwie ja jetzt ist der kopf
halt immer falls die sache ist
allerdings dass oben immer noch die zeit
von dem race abläuft also ich glaube ich
muss das race wirklich irgendwie beenden
ich weiß allerdings nicht wo dieses
komische auto mein fahrrad hin
verfrachtet hat ich glaube das ist die
schlechteste race zeit die je ein
golfsimulator spieler erreicht hat in
der tat die dritte und letzte sache die
ich euch allerdings noch kurz mitteilen
möchtest dass ich heute um 19 uhr einen
kurzen knackigen instagram leibchen
mache also schaut gern vorbei ich als
der laser luca und dann sehen wir es
dort vielleicht also hier vorne ist das
nächste tor was sich irgendwie erreichen
muss die sache ist nur ich habe halt
kein fahrrad ich wollte noch mal um
gefahren vielleicht ist das paar
allerdings wieder an dem spawn punkte da
könnte ich mal eben kurz nachschauen
also hier rechts um die kurve war das ja
glaube ich da steht allerdings kein
fahrer doch da oh my god okay dass das
fahrrad für eurostat raid sammer wollte
mich fertig
schon die ganze zeit bei dem race dabei
aber okay ich glaube wir müssen das
ganze race jetzt einfach noch mal machen
ist vor unserer zeit auch deutlich
besser also als erstes hier vorne durch
das tor durch genau dann fahren wir
weiter durch das tor genau hier weiter
vorne durch hier zeigt ich glaube im
echten chance auf den weltrekord wenn
paar sekunden später war der lkw lang
fährt bei der tour de france auch und
jetzt habe ich durch die fahrradlenkerin
also von der tote frau ist bin ich noch
weit entfernt allerdings werde ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich oder ich hoffe zumindest
dass sich unter diesen sieben minuten
comedy ich gerade hatte allerdings sieht
es gar nicht mal so schlecht aus weil
ich habe endlich mal diese verdammte
steuerung begriffen und zwar muss man
wirklich einfach nur mit der maus lenken
und mit den pfeiltasten muss man
irgendwie das gleichgewicht halten also
jetzt hier links rum aha mein gott ich
bin auch ich bin eine form einfach
stehen bleibt stehen
oder du bleibt stehen bleibt stehen
bleibt stehen verstehen das ist nicht
wahr haben
das ist nicht wahr ich mag diese strecke
überhaupt ihre füße durch meinen körper
durch
wow ich bin ich will zu und hier oben
tanzen
ich wollte einfach nur zu meinem fahrrad
wir waren so kurz davor eine richtig
gute zeit raus zu hauen und jetzt ein
video auf dem dach mit zwei tanzenden
leuten ja ich kann es nicht oft genug
sagen herzlich willkommen zur
gottesmutter mit luca da ist er auch
schon wieder am tanzen vor uns aber
meine damen und herren wir haben ein
ziel und das ist das gewinnen dieses
races bzw was gewinnen also werden wir
nicht mehr gegner angefahren quasi
einfach nur gegen die zeit
hier vorne ist auf jeden fall unser
paradies das ist doch nicht der erste
bin ich jetzt wieder so far away alles
klar
lasst mich direkt über mein fahrrad ist
irgendwo hier vorne genau hier vorne
liegt es rum das heißt ich nehme das
jetzt habe ich das okay ich habe
irgendwie wieder weggeschickt haben
jetzt fahren wir hier vorne ganz langsam
um die kurve genau das machen wir sehr
gut man dann und jetzt hier um die ko
ich schon wie am boden stehe auf nehmen
wir das fahrrad und weiter geht's so wir
müssen einfach nur motiviert sein wir
müssen einfach nur an uns glauben solche
vorne den berg hoch hier vorne ist
nämlich dass
[Musik]
trauriger ist ich mache das ja nicht
mehr extra das ist spiels einfach so am
arsch gefahren jetzt einfach rückwärts
und dann fangen wir wieder vorwärts hier
durch das tor durch und jetzt ganz
langsam drehen wir das ding im kreis
sehr gut mein gott da hin wer das ziel
gewesen ich lass das fahrrad jetzt
einfach weiter den berg runter rollen
bis deswegen die von alleine das ziel
erreicht hatte und dann kann ich auch
eigentlich nicht groß was falsch machen
allerdings trifft das fahrrad nicht so
ganz
ich lag da nichts mehr als okay wir
gehen zum fahrrad hin drücken er fahren
um die technik wo bin ich auf mein
fahrrad da okay abfahrer wieder hin
freunde mir wieder ziehen mittlerweile
alles ein bisschen suzuki optiker ich
will ich komme nicht hoch es hängt
effekt in mein einziges ziel ist es
dieses gottverdammte rennen
abzuschließen ich dachte wirklich
schaffen jetzt eine super geile zeit
aber warte moment wie heinz j 12 67 39
ja weil sie nicht so gut und wie kann
jetzt diese person hier von mir runter
also ich habe keine ahnung was hier
abgeht ich weiß nicht wie ich diese
person loswerde
allerdings hatte ich auch für das
heutige wieder eigentlich ein ganz
anderen plan als dass wir dieses
komische race machen heimlich hat nur
dieses fahrrad gesehen und dachte hey
das wäre vielleicht lustig aber jetzt
ist das video schon fast vorbei das sind
dass solbakken das
weil ich jetzt nicht könnte man hier
fordern auch ein stück weiter hoch
laufen ich glaube hier war ich vor ein
paar jahren tatsächlich schon mal in
einem anderen video und hier oben ist
irgendwie ihr ist gar nichts ich weiß
wirklich fast gar nichts mehr von den
ganzen gott simulator videos die ich vor
jahren auf einem kanal hochgeladen habe
allerdings glaube ich war hier schon mal
denn hier ist diese ringe teil steht ihr
okay und das bist du
head back brot steht da unten also das
erscheint das scheint eine ziel zu sein
da gut lassen wir die komische ziel
gemacht da vorne liegen laufen hier
vorne runter wieder
ich weiß nicht ob ich mit dem ufo noch
irgendwas anstellen kann bzw soll ich
glaube aber ich habe auch diese mission
mit dem ufo gegen die damals schon
gemacht
das ist auf jeden fall unsere welt ja
schön was machen die da vorne hat jetzt
möchte ich noch mal kurz anschauen ich
bin auf die fresse geflogen das guck dir
sagt deniz siga mit der frau andrea habe
ich auch noch nie gesehen ich habe keine
ahnung was die jungs hier vorne machen
es sieht so aus als hätten die gerade
etwas zu essen gemacht bzw
naja ok oh mein gott das ist willig
schmerzen auf meiner taufen rücken hey
was geht war da wird ja jetzt sehen sie
auf jeden fall beide ein bisschen
komisch aus aber mein gott hätten brennt
ich war ja früher vorher wehrmann 1938
im krieg darf ich das feuer gelöscht und
das ist gar kein feuer und fackeln das
geht was ist denn hier los mittlerweile
täglich wirklich absolut rein gar nichts
mehr ich glaube man hier runter und hier
vorne wieder madame die auch meine
madame ist
warum ist eine komische mobil
irgendwie
verstehe ich die welt nicht mehr
und irgendwie
mach die heutige folge dass auch vorne
und hinten und an den seiten absolut
keinen sinn wenn daher meine damen und
herren wenn ich das video der stelle
jetzt auch beenden ich habe wirklich gar
keinen plan was sich im heutigen video
geschafft habe beziehungsweise gemacht
habe beziehungsweise was ich machen
wollte
weil die mieter habt ihr glaube ich
mittlerweile selbst begriffen dass
schmeiß dich irgendwo rein und dann
machst du das einfach wenn sich
allerdings dennoch gefallen da würde ich
mich selbst er dort über einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freund schreibt mir zudem gerne und die
kommentare was sich im nächsten semester
machen sollen abonniert main kanal falls
sie noch kein teil der luchs usaid
übrigens kommen am 11 12 neue klamotten
den shop also ich hoffe da freut ihr
euch drauf
ciao
[Musik]